a victory for Israeli settlers as the
nested lifts a ban on four settlements
in the occupied West Bank it allows
settlers to return to Illegal outposts
18 years after they were ordered to
leave in 2005 then prime minister Ariel
Sharon agreed that Israel would withdraw
from Gaza and Seed the settlements under
a future deal with the Palestinians
Israel has now reneged on that agreement
everything exists there except for the
people the houses the people who were
evacuated and the houses that were
destroyed now we came to fix it and
there will be a town there
the Palestinian Authority has denounced
the movement
I think when they returned to these
so-called homish settlement and other
settlements this will show us that this
government is going ahead with its plan
to take and Annex the lands and continue
its open battle against the Palestinian
people
the EU Israeli Ally the U.S have
condemned the decision
last month
Israeli government announced
nine settlements in the occupied West
Bank since the 1967 war Israel has
established around 140 outposts on
Palestinian land the settlements are
illegal under international law and the
U.N has previously described them as a
war crime the Israel is retreating from
International commitment
Israel is denying a decision of its own
Supreme Court to return the land of
those settlements to its private
Palestinian owners
and it also denies a law the law of
disengagement which was
accepted in 2005 when when Israel pulled
out from Gaza
the changes are the latest in a series
of controversial moves by prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's far-right coalition
government which took charge in December
it comes at a time of height intentions
and the worst violence between Israelis
and Palestinians in recent years